[MUSIC]
When we talk about the OMS program
we sometimes use the metaphor,
where's the classroom?
On campus, we have a physical classroom
and it's where the discussion,
the announcements,
the lecturing all happen.
In my opinion, in the OMS program,
Piazza is the classroom.
The lectures are on Udacity like
a textbook and t square is there for
assignments and resources.
But Piazza is where we recreate the
personal interactions that are present
in a typical classroom.
So we'll talk about getting
started with Piazza.
And we'll talk about asking questions,
reading responses, and
providing answers of your own.
Now, Piazza can get extremely
noisy in classes of this size, so
we'll also talk about some workflows for
managing your time on Piazza.
We generally recommend checking in on
Piazza each day while you're enrolled in
a class, even for
only a couple of minutes.
Just to see if anything
catches your eye or
if there is any place you can
help your classmates out.